Honduras is one of the poorest countries
in Central and South America it has the
highest murder rate in the world almost
double the rate of the next closest
contender
it's a place ravaged by the drug trade
and plagued by political instability a
place where the military recently ousted
the president after he began exploring
his options to rewrite the Constitution
and extend his own term it may seem like
one of the last places on earth where
businesses want to invest and outsiders
would want to move but there's a new
idea about to be tried in Honduras it's
called a Zed a politically autonomous
privately run zone that supporters
believe could transform not only
Honduras but the entire developing world
the laws are all in place investors are
lined up and ready to go
and the big questions about to be
answered will this actually work
one of the biggest challenges of poor
person faces in the world today
is the inability to access good law and
governance Zach Casares is the executive
director of the startup cities Institute
a research organization based out of
Guatemala's University of Francisco
marroquín on the one hand we are really
good at making better physical
technologies cell phones always get
better computers always get better
cameras always get better on the other
hand you have social technologies you
have the ways in which we organize
ourselves our law and governance systems
these are not subject to entrepreneurial
trial and error in fact they're
essentially locked away from competition
and innovation when you see someone who
is in grinding poverty but they have a
smartphone you can really see this
paradox on display and what I'm
suggesting is let's bring the same kind
of progress the same kind of benefit of
entrepreneurial trial-and-error to
social tech that we already know works
in physical tech because fundamentally
both of these things are technology and
they are open to innovation the way that
it works is that it designates
particular zones that enjoy a high
degree of autonomy in particular in
areas of commercial law independent
police force labor law various other
kinds of things the idea is to develop
different areas in Honduras with
institutions that the Reformers hope
will be better for the economic
development of the countries the
Honduran Congress first passed
legislation creating special zones in
2011 but the project hit a roadblock
when one of its most high-profile
proponents economist Paul Romer pulled
out and disavowed the project citing
transparency concerns the Supreme Court
soon thereafter declared the plan
unconstitutional the Congress then
amended the Constitution and passed a
new version of the legislation this
opened the door for what in Honduras are
known as the zones for employment and
economic development or zetz it's a very
exciting moment because this project if
it accomplishes what it's capable of
doing will demonstrate inside of
Honduras and to the world that the
capacity for solving problems and for
creating jobs
particular can go forward with a
velocity that very few people have been
expecting mark Klugman is a former
Reagan speechwriter and board member on
the committee for the adoption of best
practices the board that has final
approval over proposed zones Klugman has
worked with reformers in several
countries over the last few decades and
until now he's always approached reform
in a more orthodox way by tackling one
issue at a time I had an awakening which
was what will never arrive this way
Klugman likes to refer to the idea as a
leap zone visualized as a chair with
four legs legal economic administrative
and political take out one leg and the
chair loses stability and investors flee
what happens if you say our constant
will be time we want all of them
immediately and simultaneously the model
is the constant that's the starting
point is everything and then the
variable becomes what space land area
right now you have people who live in
places that that have bad governance in
the case of Honduras they have very
serious governance challenges and you
have people who are willing to risk
their lives on extremely dangerous
journeys across national borders to
access other forms of law and governance
they're voting with their feet for
different systems
I think startup cities is a much more
humane way of dealing with ISM so for me
what startup cities is about is actually
lowering the barriers of entry to good
governance for the average person
no Hondurans EDS have yet been launched
but Klugman expects the committee to
begin reviewing proposals in the next
several months in the meantime there are
some existing areas in Honduras that
might act as a preview of what's to come
you
you